hi good evening and thank the organizers
and the stickers today and you for
staying at the tower so I'm presenting
work that was done in Tel Aviv
University by me and two doctors dr.
gorenberg dome who is an expert in
active learning it's anyone interested
in the amount of time we are and I'm a
material scientist material is
completely different things and data
different state of energy and but I'm
going to take you for a journey to my
field and then I will show you how how
deep learning works in for my world and
so first of all this is a bit about
chemistry
don't think that I am talking about
chemistry the alchemy had a motto that
Oh which means pray let me let it
relegate which means Lauren Lauren and
then we learn and then the bewitchment
works
so before we start working and talking
about the deep learning I will learn a
bit about computational physics and
there's some stories about applications
and but you probably can take it also to
the learning to things and so material
science and all the materials that we
have around the micro electronics optics
electrochemistry a chemical reaction
drug discovery everything that is based
on items I'm not not hire vegetables or
all the other physics that around us and
I'm going to I started my PhD when the
question was how can we improve them
vehicles in the factories for vehicles
one of the problems with electrical cars
is that the battery doesn't stay for
long enough so we have a bunch of
materials that can help help us to
improve the batteries but how do you
choose your material how do you know
where to start and how would it work and
so battery just in general this is where
short journey there is a cathode and I
want the here here it is not here it is
a cathode and something in between this
is kind of capacitor so probably for
those who studied studied physics in
school and the electrolyte is a kind of
magic because you can put there whatever
you want which there are a lot of fake
criteria so I would it be pulled or not
and you you have tens of materials to
choose there so how do we start
you can search Google you have to try
your materials in the world but what can
help you in real life is the
computational experiments sorry and I've
just run the movie so what you see here
is the others running in computational
experiment and this is the actual
experiment to 3d for oxygen in the day
electrolyte traveling between direct
Rowland so if you want to do it in the
lab it will take like hey years of work
if you want to do it in a computer in
computational experiment you can't you
can't actually model this vessel but you
can model
hundreds or thousands of bantams depends
on the resolution you decide to work
with so and so a bit about computational
experiment because I'm a computational
science of material scientist and so we
have a lot of skills to learn about the
the the if you talk about the the world
system it should be about millimeters
and the way it works for seconds or
hours or more even more but this is the
full battery if you take part of this
battery at the end we have some kind of
dishes for example the cathode this is
this electron microscope picture
cluttered and here we have some my
microns few microns probably and so all
the cathode there is a chemical reaction
that happens and this is the reaction
that give us the energy for the battery
this is the interaction that received
energy so we need oxygen we need lithium
and we need an electron which should
come to the same point the patent and
then we have energy for the butter and
so what does it mean in a sense of our
methods in computational chemistry we
have a lot of methods but each methods
actually fits only for a specific scale
for example we can treat the quantum
level since the turret nanometers few
nanometers and we can treat classically
atomistic classically as you saw in the
movie before four nanometers or
micrometers and you also can you have
even a more advanced method that can
treat a with
it's larger scales things but the
problem with this method that you will
not see chemical reactions there and the
chemical reaction is the most important
thing for the energy was similar energy
from the battery so if you don't if we
can't if we can't end model it
we can't model the vessel the another
problem with this method is that as you
go for a larger scale you need more and
more parameters that you need to fit
somehow probably from experiments and
that cost a lot of money and time money
everything and so what we do in our
experiment we run a very pretty each
item as a point it moves by know we know
somehow what is the force that act on it
and then we so we move with it for some
times and then we have a lot of pattern
moving for example here you can see
probably bit more atoms but this is the
electrolyte for another electrolyte
without the oxygen and so the model is
what is the force that act on each atom
this is this is the main problem for me
how do I know what is the force that act
on each of atom and then there are some
classical models this is probably
something you know from a static physics
just two balls which are charge they
repel and or attractor or whatever and
so it's everything about the
interruption the interaction is actually
a quantum thing and then just know this
to know the what is the interaction this
is about labeling how
although a label in my field and the
interaction is something I want to label
and then I need to run a simulation
quantum mechanical solution is a PDE
creation and then for many many
variables you have to solve it it takes
about two weeks on Cluster for realistic
systems that they show you for you each
point I mean each data point takes two
weeks your own cluster not on my PC so
it is pretty expensive thing just to
explain you when I need to know the
diffusion constant for example I need
million points so this experiment is
just not realistic for me for now but so
so here we come we want we can say what
would what do we want we want a fast and
accurate enough model for a to Mystic
Falls at least the first is the output
of my mother and when we wanted to beat
temperature transferrable I mean if the
system is heated up the interaction
shouldn't fall down so it should be
Delta tu transferrable and sky scalable
the size scalable what do I mean I can
train my I can get data for 100 atoms I
can get data for South and atoms form if
I have a large cluster but I can get
data for realism I do want to emit to
simulate real vessels so I and I can't
get such solutions just from
computational expense expense of it so
if I could learn from small systems but
apply it on large system this this would
be good for
our mothers this is the main goal of my
work and another problem with deployment
which you probably know that it is
imagine no one understand why does it
works and we try to see what can we
learn about the physics from the model
because the model is definitely not like
your like standard physical models where
you do know what you do you you assume
some kind of interaction here you don't
assume anything we just make this linear
algebra as you know and does it actually
learn some physics so this was a
question and we try to answer it so now
let's go to work
what are the methods so the general idea
is a bit we long we make few few
solvents of quantum mechanical
calculations of two weeks calculations
and then we make learning some learning
for a long time because the system
actually doesn't change as you saw a lot
of small movements doesn't actually
change the interaction but once in why
you have this quantum reaction so you
need to learn in again now you have a
new data and you have to run more
quantum mechanical calculations so it
takes some time but then you learn again
the de space your new part of space and
then you can work with the machine
learning model this machine learning
model doesn't have to be deploying it -
there were some sin and your son Carol
methods and even more and but I worked
with a deep neural network so the
question for me was about what is the
input and you can treat it as it as an
image as a medical imaging
you hear the before but you have to
remember that most of the matter is just
empty there are no nothing there there
are no data there so the data is only on
the atoms so what we know we drink out
of each way you take each time one atom
the output is the force that that it
feels and the input is just the
neighbors and there is a physical Turing
that it's not a torrents an axiom in
quantum mechanics that every that if you
know the position if you know the
location of all the atoms and its type
just the type from the table the really
table you know everything about the
system you so the rhythm model there
exist model that can know everything
about the system now you should just
find this model so we take this input
the distances between atoms this is the
central atom the time interested in this
is the its neighbor and the neighbors
actually define the surrounding it's
like a patch in a segmentation problem
probably but bit different because this
is not an image and so this is the input
the model is pretty simple it's
completely saves you from yes okay for
my problems for my problems I wasn't
interested in magnetic properties or
some organized pin spin related
properties when you do labeling you take
it in account so you can't do it I mean
you have the data I didn't ask about the
spinet I asked about the force the
classical mechanical force but it fit
but you can do it and then people do it
I mean other what I'm looking for forces
for atomic each for each of them possess
some force so this is the first this is
the vector with three components the
time interested in this is the F X at Y
Z this is my output and my input is just
the position position of neighbors I
decide about the number of units let let
you decide about the neighborhood and
this is this is the input for because
they also included filter of 1 over
distance and this is because to make it
with neural network take a lot much
larger and networks more models so and I
know that I need it from physical models
yes by distance yes it is important and
so we have a model we have training data
and we optimize with usual methods we
use just standard Python libraries and
here is their results so those are
results from quantum mechanics and those
are results from our model and you can
see that they are pretty same for pretty
same forces and it's really small
numbers here and good enough for
whatever properties the time interested
in so this is this was done for few
materials few different materials at
different temperatures and then we
started to ask questions about
transferability so let us talk about
temperature
what does it change when you increase
the temperature of something of solid it
becomes like softy right more so and
this means that the system becomes more
amorphous and less ordered then it's low
temperature so you can't learn from a
morphic system for an unordered system
to all those system but you don't expect
your the model to learn from non firm
order system to non auto system so this
is what we got when we started at large
temperatures when we when we learned our
system with low temperature data which
mean it was more amorphous we got a good
result for low temperatures this this is
what you can see here when we start
working with the
when we teach your data on your model on
the data low temperatures
labels then you can learn nothing you
can learn nothing you can see this
beautiful brush that just have a larger
nose
okay I use 2000 Kelvin which means they
are still kind of non gas all the
materials so they still kind of solid
and low temperature zone temperature
basically when using a battery my car
something like that
still the load yeah so I can use this
model for temperature and yeah why don't
you use the siren and you don't always
okay first of all tourism the
temperature define the probability of
the system to be in debt and debt
position state and it doesn't define the
positions do not define the temperature
but somehow temperature affects the
distribution of the of the states they
affect the distribution of the data but
you don't you don't have strange called
systems because there is no phase
condition you don't have no this is the
narrow but and I I don't see phase
transitions here I would be interested
in it and this is like kind of further
questions that we have yes
and what we have to make some proof of
concept and this works are started and
2012 was medical science there and there
are very few groups in the world that
work on it last year it was Google group
that started so it is it is much slower
than medical images development and this
is kind of first try so once I have been
a long model I it takes less than a
second on my PC and then I can run me
leonov if it makes possible to make real
experiments so the most interesting for
a question for me was can I learn from
small systems to large one this was the
main challenge because I if there isn't
limit that I can't go over it with the
quantum mechanics and I want to trust my
model with larger systems so this is
what you see here is an arrows that are
shown for assist the poor model learned
from small systems and tested on large
systems no large system data you get a
computed precisely no here this is large
systems that I could compute I track it
this is the test but but look at the
numbers here it's like 1 125 atoms it is
still small but it is per 4 times larger
than this and it takes a like instead of
2 days 2 weeks still still it may
emitters make sense somehow and that I
can trust the model to go into larger
systems so and now what can we learn
from this system so what we try to
understand is the parameterization how
many inputs do I need how many neighbors
should I take in account when I am build
my model and then we saw that for for
materials that has more nearest
neighbors we need more neighbors in the
model so somehow it understands at least
the dead basic thing that it's not clear
exactly where it converges how many
neighbors do I need but example at this
point for example for 12 numbers 12 12
nearest neighbors for aluminium and this
is the number of near of first nearest
neighbors for me
and it converges almost there so it
implementers physically yes yes it is
although the systems that I trained on
are amorphous kind of amorphous but it
is related to crystal structure because
the difference between the amorphous and
crystal structures somehow related also
and so we show we have shown that there
is sufficient you are see that we can
show with these kind of models in
material science we showed the larger
system for forces that we can predict
predicted the lower temperature systems
with a higher temperature systems and we
had the we understood some physical
insight from the parameterization so
then the main brands puzzle in Europe is
really France I have two and you for
stayin yet and questions you need to
work on the simulation and then they go
back and so I don't yeah why not okay I
like show you a realistic example of
what I'm trying to do you have this
battery you start with the you start
with oxygen in some kind of surrounding
atoms then it goes to the cathode
once it meets the cathode I don't have
the data for it
if I know if I know if I know that it
will goes there I can do it but
sometimes I don't want to do it because
I want the system to not to find the
path this is this is a while you can say
why don't you just train your sister
you're a model on a large amount of
systems and different see completely
different systems and then you find the
different model and other than quantum
mechanical model and then you use
yourself like the huge problem there is
a problem for calculation for quantum
mechanics if we can find a linear model
for to describe evolving everything in
physics even it nice but the problem is
then you need a huge Network I don't
want it I want my network simulation yes
physical system ok yes when you saw this
i I didn't yes we want to but first of
all we know there are the theoretical
model we know the precision of for and
then if you look here this this is like
the distribution function where are the
neighbors distribution and the black one
is for the crystal way
alumina which is really related to the
experimental one the red one and the
blue one are for different temperatures
with the simulation but you can see that
they are the peaks are at the same
places and this is the relationship
between the different temperatures but
we didn't compare directly to experiment
yet but it would be interesting for us
so is it matching some theoretical
statistical mechanics yes
the idea is to solve statistical
mechanics problems such as finding
diffusion constant finding phase
transitions finding this kind of stuff
so then you need statistics and then you
need millions of states to average over
millions of states to find this property
that's why I need the force yes also the
tool that you lose for at the Soviet
shown no not yet
yes but but exactly and there are some
works that are very close to that
[Applause]